the thing that most of us get wrong
about manifesting is that we have this
big dream like publishing a book or
launching a podcast and all you dream
about is the end that's it you miss the
bridge between where you are and the
thing that you want and so let's use
another metaphor everybody okay
let's use the metaphor of running a
marathon so a marathon is 26.2 miles how
many of you have on your bucket list
someday it would be amazing to run and
complete a marathon that would be
something pretty cool to do before I die
now you may have a million excuses for
why it's not going to happen but just
allow the dream to flow through you have
you ever wanted to Summit a mountain
Mount Kilimanjaro have you ever wanted
to run you know a marathon it doesn't
matter we're going to use this as a
teaching tool so let's say that your
goal is to run a marathon 26.2 miles
okay the mistake that everybody makes is
they literally visualize
crossing the Finish Line That's not how
manifesting Works hey it's Evan
Carmichael and I make these videos
because in my first business I quit on
my business partner I was making 300
bucks a month and I didn't have the
motivation to keep going and the thing
that got me through was studying the
stories of entrepreneurs who've had
massive success and I hope that in
sharing these stories with you you find
a motivation to keep going and if I'm
being honest I still need the source for
myself today too so today let's learn
from some of the best and figure out how
to activate the Law of Attraction enjoy
a manifesting remember is the bridge
that's going to get you to the finish
line
manifesting is preparing you it's like a
training run so what do you manifest
what do you visualize when you want to
complete a marathon
you got to visualize the pain in the
rear end stuff you got to visualize
running in the rain
visualize your alarm going off at 5 30
in the morning it's dark it's cold you
don't want to get out of bed but you're
five four three two one get out of bed
and then you visualize yourself pulling
on your tights and the dog is looking at
you and you visualize walking through a
quiet apartment or house and then you
visualize opening up the front door and
oh it's raining and you visualize that
you don't want to go outside and maybe
you'll skip the run but then you
visualize grabbing your raincoat and
going out that door and then you know
what you visualize you visualize
yourself at Mile seven on a training run
and your earbuds the batteries die oh
and you just want to give up but guess
what you keep running
that's the kind of stuff that you
visualize you visualize the hard the
annoying the stuff you don't want to do
if you want to make more money you
better visualize uh staying in on the
weekends and working on your business
instead of blowing your cash at the bar
if you want to have a different uh
relationship with your spouse you should
visualize going to counseling or
listening to books about how to improve
your relationship and working on
yourself
seriously you gotta visualize the hard
stuff rule number two be in harmony with
your vibration with Bob Proctor
attraction
um
is not a it's a secondary law it isn't a
primary law the primary law is a lot of
vibration and the law of vibration
decrees that everything moves nothing
rests we live in a notion of motion
circulation being one of the first laws
in the universe when stuff when
circulation stops death sets in
well
we operate on a frequency you do I do
and what we're really attempting to do
is raise the frequency that we're
operating on we want to operate on a
higher frequency all the time because
that's where the real beauty of life is
well this thing we're living in is a
molecular structure in a very high speed
of vibration
and the brain is an electronic switching
station that alters the vibration we're
in
well we operate on a frequency and the
only thing we can attract to us is that
which is in resonance with us
so the reaction is actually attraction
it's like Emerson said the law of cause
and effect was the law of Lies Action
Reaction this is the law of cause and
effect well our thoughts feelings and
actions we send off
into the universe it's a vibration
the universe sends it back it responds
in like manner well the response of the
universe is the attraction
you can only attract to you what
vibrates in harmony with you so if we
see things coming into our life that we
don't like let's understand what we
don't like is in harmony with something
inside
so we better try and understand what it
was or what it is and then get rid of it
attractions a secondary law
and we've got to understand it is very
real and you only attract to you what
you're in harmony with
when you want something that's on a
higher frequency you've got to operate
on that higher frequency because all the
thoughts and things that you require are
on that higher frequency
most people I say are living on an AM
frequency trying to listen to FM music
it doesn't work how do you know what
vibrational frequency level you're
operating at uh because people often
judge their
people judge their performance by their
productivity by their efficiency we're
not trained as you said with your
Paradigm again going back to that we're
not trained to observe our frequency and
vibration and people are not sure so if
someone's listening and watching us
today how do they know what their
vibration or their frequency is how do
they diagnose that well I think the only
way to do it is by the results you're
getting
it'll tell you right makes sense see the
results do tell the truth they don't lie
Spirit manifests through its polar
opposite always we're Spiritual Beings
Spirit flows to and through us
and will do anything for us whatever we
ask it'll give us
and we're asking in thought
so what we want to do is take a look
what have I been thinking take a look at
your results you'll know what you're
thinking
that's how you can tell the frequency
you're on you want to start
frequencies vibration vibrations feeling
when you say I feel bad what you're
really saying is I'm not in a very good
vibration
you say I feel particularly good you're
saying I'm in a pretty good vibration
conscious awareness of vibration is
referred to as feeling
hmm
so I think the way to really understand
the frequency and the vibrations you're
operating on is by the results you're
getting
yeah if you're continually having
problems in all areas of your life
you're on the wrong you're on the wrong
vibration you know very low level of
vibration
and we can change it rule number three
do less to attract more with Gabby
Bernstein I can do less and attract more
boom people I can do less and attract
more
that is actually one of my favorite
passages from Super attractor do less
and attract more it's such a heart
Opening way of living because often we
live in this way where we think the
harder I push the more I do the more
pain I have the more I suffer the more I
will succeed the more I will accomplish
it's so the opposite when we push when
we control when we try to force things
into form we really get in the way in my
book super attractor I talk about being
a manic manifester someone who's
constantly trying to do all the
spiritual things to try to make things
happen but manifesting is quite the
opposite manifesting is doing less and
attracting more being more receptive to
the energy that is around us being more
open to that heart-centered place within
us and not forcing or pushing or trying
to control because all that control and
all that pushing and all that doing gets
in the way of all of our capacity to
receive
so I bet this will be a topic that will
come up over and over again on this
episode do less and attract more it
always shows us what we need the cards
reveal the theme for the show let's see
what comes through say that affirmation
just for a moment to yourself before we
bring in our guests I can do less and
attract more just say that to yourself I
can do less and attract more
and just feel into that doesn't that
feel good to just say that to yourself I
can do less and attract more wow what a
nice
different perspective on life
I've trained myself to live in that way
I've lived that way the opposite of that
for over two decades I'm sure maybe over
three decades I was pushing and
controlling now at 41 I'm finally
allowing myself to step back to give
things away to ask for help to do less
and attract more I can testify that the
less you push and control the less you
try to do do the more you will receive
also to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching this video I've
designed a special free worksheet just
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the Lessons Learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there rule number four focus on what you
want with Dean graziosi I want to share
one thing this is relevant to you with
everything I'm reading combine that
there was a gentleman when Tony does
date with Destiny he literally asks if
there's anybody in the audience that's
thinking about suicide pretty tough
question to ask and Tony says I'm
guessing about 10 with the size of this
audience nine people raised their hand
this gentleman raised his hand and
Tony Tony walks out in the audience gets
right off to him and says can tell me
what's going on in your life he's like
well my mom was sick when I was young so
I quit college and decided to take care
of her for a year and he said a year
turned into 20 something years and she
lasted and I was there taking care of
her and he's like I never dated I didn't
go out and now my mom passed away and he
said I am the person gets made fun of at
the office I don't know how to dress
I've never been with a woman I've never
even kissed a woman I don't know how to
date I've tried online dating and I
embarrassed myself there's no purpose
this life I go to work I get nothing I'm
not I don't want to be here anymore so
Tony does some things that are
completely shocked I want to go up and
hug the guy but Tony was right he's the
one who knows how to do this Tony
shocked him and said all right that
story would make me want to kill myself
how long you've been telling that crap
story and that's only done not because
he doesn't care he wants to shock him
out of this state of like getting into
it right so long story short what I want
to share with you is this Tony does some
things he gets him he gets him up on
stage and he gets two chairs and he puts
a chair over here and he puts a chair
over here and he puts a white board here
and he puts a white board over here
and this is the lesson for today he says
to him okay I'm I hear all the things
you're going through tell me what you
don't want so Tony writes really sloppy
if you've ever been to his event you
can't even read what he says he says
what don't you want and the guy says he
says I don't want to be alone I'm going
to just scribble I'm not going to Rattle
this out I'm just gonna tell you and
this is how fast Tony is I don't want to
be alone I don't want to get made fun of
I don't want to feel insecure
I don't wanna
I don't want to be in a job I hate and
this guy goes on and Tony can't write as
fast as what he doesn't want he doesn't
want to be sad at night he doesn't want
to feel that he's facing the world all
by himself he doesn't want to feel like
a weirdo when he goes to he literally
said weirdo when he goes to a party and
leaves insecure and Tony's just writing
and scribbling like this and Tony's
making a mess and he's like whoo okay so
he gets Tony Tony gets him up comes over
to this other chair sits him in the
other chair and he says what
do want what do you want
he says okay tell me what you want and
the guy sits there and goes
um I don't want to be alone anymore no
no no that's on this list that's what
you don't you don't want to be alone
okay tell me
he says he thinks he says
um
I don't want to get made fun of anymore
Tony goes that's what you don't want
this gentleman could not say for minutes
it seemed like an hour what he wanted
so think about that that's like
getting in your car and you're going to
go on a trip and you get in the car and
the family's in the car the kids are in
the back and you say we're going on a
trip
um we're not going to go to Florida
let's go
well where the hell are you going and
then I combine that with all everything
I'm reading and knowing my personal life
and the things I've manifested and
thought about when you think about what
you don't want if you think about I
don't want to be alone I don't want to
be alone I don't want to be alone I
don't want to be alone what happens you
are alone because what you put your
attention on is what you get this poor
guy did not have a list of what he
wanted finally he said I want to be in a
relationship Tony said Hallelujah he
wants something what kind of girl do you
want he went oh I don't know
he didn't even he wanted a relationship
he barely knew he wanted a relationship
when he said he wanted a relationship he
didn't know what kind of girl what what
color hair how old what she did for a
living do you want somebody who's
positive negative what he he literally
spent so many years thinking about what
he didn't want all he kept doing is
compounding and manifesting what he
didn't want and I watched this life this
guy's life changed when he did simply
one thing made a list of what he wanted
and Tony said to him and then again all
the things that I've done in my own
personal life what if you woke up
tomorrow and made sure you didn't think
about what you didn't want you just
envisioned what you wanted and it was
coming true
tomorrow will be the same no matter what
you tell your brain if you're in debt if
you have an illness right now if you
don't feel the best you're going through
a divorce or a troubled relationship or
you're in a dead relationship or you
don't know how to fix it here's the
thing if you focus on what you don't
want it's still going to be there either
way but what if you focus on making that
relationship finding a spark or maybe
ending something that's really bad or
finding somebody new or focus on yes I'm
in debt right now but I'm going to focus
on where I want to go when I'm not out
of debt because again tomorrow we'll be
there and you will be in living in the
moment you're in and you have a choice
do I want to focus on what's wrong and
what I don't want or do I want to focus
on what I do on that was such a powerful
thing when I got to watch that firsthand
and I watched him go from this guy in a
state of wanting to kill himself writing
his what he wanted and Tony went deep on
him do you know 15 minutes later he was
up on stage they spiked his hair they
rolled up his sleeves he was on stage
dancing like I had never seen the smile
is was probably he said it was the most
funny it ever had in his life only
because he stopped thinking for just one
minute what he didn't want and started
thinking what he did well number five is
break the negative thought pattern with
Rhonda Byrne if you would just think
about what you want that's all you'd
ever get in your life it's as simple as
that but a lot yeah a lot of people
think a lot of negative things
consistently it's on a loop that just
holds them into this negative pattern so
how do we break that negative thought
pattern right so so you I mean the mind
is like a computer program so and and
the fact that it's on a negative Loop is
because we programmed it on the negative
Loop but but you know we could have been
influenced from her children and things
like that so
um so one of the things that the Mind
loves is loves repetition I mean he
loves it you know if you really watch
your thoughts this is the same old
thoughts over and over again you know
it's just kind of dishing up the same
old thing so it loves repetition so the
way you can override a program is to put
in the opposite you know and when you
start out you know you feel like you're
lying you know you'll say something like
you know you might be really broke gee I
was when I was making the secret so
um you might not have any money and
you're trying to instill you know wealth
and prosperity and riches and every time
you say it you feel a contraction in
your body because you know you don't
have it but you know truly because I did
it myself after a while you change it
you re you really begin to change it and
you don't quite have that contraction
anymore and then you start to see money
coming in you know in in different ways
um and any and and or you can be given
things that you were going to buy and
now you don't have to buy it or so you
begin to see you start to see signs of
land you know is one of the great one of
the great new thought thought um writers
would say talk about a sign of land so
you start to see sign of land now that's
what what I did in the sacred you can do
gratitude that will turn everything
around that will make you feel good that
will get you off the negative right
but those negative thoughts are coming
from beliefs held in the subconscious
mind angle number six the last one
before some very special bonus Clips is
change your beliefs once I learned
early on I was in graduate school and I
read a book called Seth speaks and it
was about all the stuff we're talking
about and uh it was a book Channel by
this woman named Jane Roberts and I said
it just rung truest truth I just said
this feels right and what she was
teaching is that your beliefs are a
choice we think our beliefs are the
result of seeing something outside of us
we say oh I believe if a spider bites
you your skin turns red because that's
what I saw happen yeah yeah but we can
hypnotize people tell them uh my thumb
is a poker hit him on the hand in their
hand will form a blister we can tell
people that this is Poison Ivy and have
given maple leaves and they'll do that
and their skin will break out in a rash
sure tell people the poison ivy is a
maple leaf run the poison ivy on it
nobody breaks out in a rash right so we
know that so much of our internal
behavior and our our feel good is
created by beliefs now then the question
I had was well what should I believe
yeah what if I believe the wrong thing
and I'm going to get myself in trouble I
had this big I was afraid to believe
anything for a while and then I realized
the only beliefs that make any sense are
the beliefs that will take you from
where you are to where you want to go so
what are the beliefs that successful
people believe you know look at Oprah
Winfrey born into poverty you know
sexually abused as a child but she
believed that she could get to where she
wanted to go someone else without that
belief didn't try so simply the belief
and it's a choice everything is a binary
Choice you're either believing something
that takes you where you want to go or
something that takes you away from where
you want to go
what is fear is fear something that you
should fear
no
I want you to imagine as you're driving
down the street in your car
and a light pops up on the dashboard a
light pops up
um
have you ever taken a hammer and hit the
light because you don't like the light
of course not that would be silly right
what if the light on the dashboard was
just a signal maybe you're low on tire
air pressure maybe you're missing air or
water in your windshield wiper maybe the
back trunk door is open isn't the signal
in your car
just for you to be aware that maybe
something is wrong or something needs
attention
is it possible that if we stop thinking
of fear as the enemy fear is one of your
biggest friends why well when you
understand how did this organism
okay develop and how does it keep us
alive
it pays attention to things okay in your
external World triggers from your
external word that could cause your
death or destruction it causes you to do
what when there is a Potential
Threat predator or threat at the door it
lights up the fear signals since
cortisol epinephrine or norepinephrine
into your bloodstream so you either know
how to fight it you run away or you
freeze hoping that the Predator will go
away so when your brain every brain
gets this signal that there is a threat
at the door
it sends a signal
in the form of a neurochemical that you
feel
now if somebody
feels this threat in their body but they
don't know how to manage the emotion we
call fear let's say there's a fear that
you have a failure and what it might
mean to your family what's what about a
fear of losing money and not having
enough to pay the rent the mortgage or
for retirement what if there's a fear of
trying something and then it not working
out and you're embarrassed or ashamed or
ridiculed or rejected or judged oh my
God if you judge me then you're gonna
reinforce my low self-esteem of myself
and then knowledge then who am I
you understand what's happening in the
circuits I'm just describing
so when our brain has this Fierce
circuit activated do you think the fear
circuit causes you to go oh hey let's
take action anyway or do you think it
goes high alert high alert high alert be
aware what's going on what if you fail
what if you succeed what succeed and
fail whenever that circuit is triggered
motivational circuit shuts down whenever
that circuit is activated your thinking
circuit shuts down all the blood flow
goes into a part of your brain to help
you do what possibly run away protect
yourself it's a protection mechanism but
here is what I want you to remember this
automatic trigger and circuit has been
evolving for millions of years but your
specific experiences since you were born
in the modeling experiential and the
um and the imprinting years caused you
to have
beliefs about things some Empower you
some disempower let me give you an
example
okay let me give you an example when I
say the word
or let me give you a difference the same
example with just a little different
story
if I say to you that I'd like to take a
big snake about five feet long and let
it Slither across your arm and around
your neck and it's a python how many of
you go oh wow that would be great
versus how many of you are going oh my
God let me run away get get it off of me
just just think of a snake slithering on
you and curling itself around your neck
how many of you are like run versus oh
my God that would be great to take a
picture of me with it so I put on social
media
so is it really the snake that is the
threat or is it your Concept in your
brain the meaning that you have
associated with a snake that is
activating for some of you the reward
center and for others the fear Center
same stake stain stimuli there isn't
even a snake here I just add you think
about it
right and it triggered that fear circuit
for some reward circuit for others so
it's never about the thing so when we
have fear of being embarrassed ashamed
ridiculed judged uh fear of
disappointing ourselves fear of failing
fear of succeeding there's 50 different
types of fears we automatically trigger
the circuit that does what stops our
action taking you need to create an
environment of Excellence Excellence
most people's environments are not
excellent the people around you the the
videos that you watch the things that
are on your wall the voices that are in
your head you have these moments that
are bold that are courageous that make
you feel Unstoppable and you can do
anything and then you fall back down
because the environment is the thing
that's keeping you small it takes a
giant effort to overcome your
environment you definitely can it's
definitely possible tons of people are
doing it but it takes that giant effort
to say I don't want to stay stuck here
most people stay stuck most people make
minimal minimal minimal improvements in
their life year over year
and if you don't want to stay where you
are right now fast forward to one year
from today you don't want to stay stuck
you want to be in a different place
could actually be physically moving but
a different place in terms of your
finances in terms of your purpose in
terms of how much you're giving and
caring and sharing and the life you want
to build you want to be somewhere
totally different like today this is not
acceptable anymore I accept that this is
where I am right now but where I end up
is not going to be the same spot as
where I am right now right if that's
your commitment the biggest shift that
will help you get from where you are now
to where you want to be is creating that
environment of Excellence what's the
fastest way to learn a language what's
the fastest way to learn Japanese well
it's to go to Japan sure you can read
some books and and you can hire a tutor
and the more intense it becomes the more
you're actually living it the faster
you're going to pick it up
so if you want to develop the mindset of
the high achiever if you want to become
that person the the people that you look
up to the the whoever of the world like
I want to be the next whoever perfect
that person the more you hang around
with them the more it's going to rub off
on you how they think because how they
think how they act how they behave how
they see the world is very different
than how you see it right now and how
the people around you definitely see the
world right now
so how do you do it how do you start to
become it well
I look at what I'm doing
and this was one of my biggest
challenges when I was getting started
and honestly still in like I think the
biggest problem in the world is a lack
of belief
I'm trying to solve the world's biggest
problem people don't believe in
themselves enough I don't you don't
Oprah doesn't people don't believe in
themselves enough for the next level so
how do you start to believe in yourself
more the thing that helped me the most
was to have these successful people
around me constantly
and so I want to share a few tactics
that I think can really help you that
has really helped me as being the shy
introverted kid who never wanted to be
in front of a camera and was making 300
bucks a month and quit on my business
partner and thought life was over right
to now hear and it's taken me 20 years
to get here so hopefully we can shorten
that path for you if you actually follow
some of the advice in this video
so step number one how do we create that
environment of Excellence
what you feed into your brain really
really matters
so figure out how you love to learn for
me it's videos I like to see things I
need to be visual if that's you then you
need to have a way to have those videos
coming into your life every day it can
be part of your morning routine that's
why I make this channel part of your
morning routine subscribe to the channel
every morning every weekday we got a new
video out there for you to give you the
shot of Express that'll help you but if
it's not my channel it's some other
channel one of my other channels
subscribe to the channels that make you
feel bold powerful Unstoppable give you
hope give you belief in yourself
and then watch that video every day or
listen to that podcast every day or read
that book every day the trick is it
can't be the same book or the the one
video because that one video on repeat
is gonna lose its Effectiveness right
you know what you watch a video gets you
all fired up and then you watch it again
the next day and it's not as like oh
what happened I don't feel as good and
you watch it the next day and the
feeling's gone so you can't just read
the same book over and over watch the
same video over and over and over again
the key is to find a consistent source
so if you love this channel you love
this video I'm making other videos just
like this
that you can subscribe to if you'd like
an author go find their other books or
go find the people that Inspire them so
that you can read something every day if
you'd like a podcast go find other
podcasts like them so you have something
every day so you you are
manipulating what comes in your head
with intention now
with intention so you're not just
scrolling through things like I am going
to watch one of these videos every day
to slowly shift myself forward because
it'll happen if you love Elon Musk and
you watch Elon Musk every day what will
happen is slowly day by day you will
start to think like Elon Musk it will
happen he will pull you forward you will
start to see the big difference in how
he thinks versus how the people around
you think versus how you think right now
and he will give you more courage and
more boldness and more
a sense of hope and purpose that you can
do it too you'll start to think more
like him so be careful who you pick and
maybe you don't like Elon Musk maybe you
like Kanye West or Oprah Winfrey or
whoever but the more you're around that
person the more you will start to think
like them so you want to put that as
part of your daily routine that every
day because yesterday was a different
day you might have been fired up bold
motivated great but today's today is a
new day
the motivation you had yesterday is
nowhere near what it is right now when
you wake up
right you got the best day of all time
you wake up the next day and it's gone
so how do you keep the consistency the
routine
tell yourself I'm going to watch a video
even when I don't want to even when I
feel low energy even when right all the
excuses we come up with I'm going to
watch a video to get myself into the
state I need to get into because I want
to follow I want to follow my dreams I
don't want to be stuck here anymore
tied to that is then subscribe to the
channels
that make you feel that way so do an
audit
of all of the channels you follow on
YouTube of all the people you follow on
Instagram anywhere you're spending time
on social
do an audit of who makes you actually
feel more bold
and who makes you just waste time
or who makes you feel bad about yourself
there's some people you probably follow
who when you look at their stuff it
actually makes you feel worse about
yourself unfollow those people
immediately right they don't care about
you so why are you caring about them
and then the people who make you feel
better
follow them subscribe to them so that
when you happen to be on the platform
when you happen to be throwing going
through YouTube or Instagram you see
them and it makes you remember why
you're doing what you do so the first
part of it is a habit we are designing
our routines around this and I'm going
to watch a video every day with my
heroes so that they pull me forward
right we're putting into our calendar
the second part of it is I'm also going
to subscribe to channels and people that
inspire me so that when I happen to be
on the platforms I'm feeding myself with
things that inspire me and lift me up
instead of waste my time or put me down
okay so that habit that environment
really really matters the second part of
environment to create our environment of
Excellence right is the physical
environment so this office inspires me
this office this was all with intent the
people on the wall behind me we got
Steve Jobs AP giannini my parents
Howard Schultz Kanye West the trophies
uh you know the YouTube stuff the the
getting
my hands wrong here this side you know
the art the art that people drew my book
uh my neck brace from when I broke my
neck like all even the colors on the
wall all of this it inspires me this
inspires me
when I walk into this office I I want to
believe more in myself
I see Steve Jobs staring me down I see
my parents staring me down it's like a
reminder of what I want to do because I
wake up and I and I don't have you know
the the most energy I don't feel super
bold and like let's go take on the day
right I don't have that as soon as I
wake up
but we manufacture it through the habits
and routines but also the actual
physical environment and the beauty
about this is you only have to set it up
once you know I set this up once and
then I walk in and every day I'm being
hit with these messages and reminders of
the person that I want to be so whether
that's a mood board you put up for
yourself where there's people that
inspire you you have to look at the
thing it inspires you to want to push
you a little harder it inspires you to
want to believe in yourself and more it
inspires you to want to go off and take
some kind of action today the physical
environment matters a lot and you can
control that so think about think about
your office think about your bedroom
think about your car think about where
you're spending significant time and how
much of that has actually been done with
intent
how much of your physical environment
has been created with intent to make you
believe in yourself more
it matters a lot and then the third
thing really quick is the actual your
outfit the clothes that you wear how you
show up for yourself when I put this on
I remind myself that I'm a superhero
going to work that might sound really
dumb or cheesy but you know what it
works for me I am a superhero going to
work I'm not fighting crime I'm fighting
lack of belief I want people to believe
in themselves more and I'm going to work
when I see there was a green arrow show
I used to watch
and when they were in their their base
in their Lair they always put their
outfits on a mannequin right so they're
when they're out fighting crime they're
in their uniforms but then when they
come back to their base they're in
normal clothes but they put their
outfits on a mannequin so I went and got
myself a mannequin it's just you can't
see it but it's just sitting here off
camera I got a mannequin and it's got my
hoodie on it as a reminder that I'm a
superhero going to work every day and
again that might sound really cheesy or
dumb or corny but I like it it works for
me and putting this on every day instead
of just showing up in my pajamas I just
I work from home
you know we've got 30 something people
on the team
I I don't seem physically that often
most people work from home I could just
show up every day in my pajamas
but putting this on
reminds me that I'm a superhero with a
mission
want to adopt that or not is up to you
but but
present yourself for yourself not just
for the camera I'm not putting this on
just for the camera I'm putting this on
because it's what I put on this is for
me
I could make a video in my pajamas
that's fine but I'm making this for me I
wear this for me what do you need to do
for you not just because there's some
expectations when your expectations of
yourself become higher than what you
think other people's expectations are
for you that's when the game starts to
change when I'm wearing something just
because of how I think you guys will
perceive me or or some speech I'm doing
or some meeting
I'm I'm only living up to that person's
standard to what I think their standards
are and said no I'm doing this for me I
wear this for me I show up like this
even if I'm not making any kind of
content I only make content once a week
usually for YouTube what are the what am
I doing the other days of the week I'm
still wearing this because I'm a
superhero going to work and it's my
reminder
this is how you start to create an
environment of Excellence guys your
environment is keeping you where you are
your environment is keeping you stuck
and if you don't want to be stuck
anymore if you want to change your
circumstances if you don't want to be in
the same spot you are right now one year
from today you have to create an
environment of Excellence
how do we do that number one we start
feeding our mind with Excellence from
the videos and podcasts and books from
people who Inspire Us number two we
change our physical environment so that
you walk into a room you walk into your
car you walk into your bedroom or office
or wherever you're spending time and it
pushes you forward to step into the
person that you want to be and then
number three The Outfits what you wear
how you present yourself having a higher
standard for yourself than what other
people expect that you are a superhero
going to work every day because you are
on a mission
you've got a great heart you've got tons
of ideas
I see it over and over and over and over
and over again
so much potential
and just stuck
just stuck
because there's a lack of momentum that
stems from having a really poor
environment
if you can just change with intention
that I am going to create an environment
of Excellence for myself that inspires
me and pushes me forward to step into
the person I want to believe that I can
be
you can do that every day
entire life will change the voice within
us that believes that we are not allowed
to be happy
our card today is speaking to that
I believe I'm worthy of feeling good I
believe I am worthy of feeling good this
is often something that is a belief
system that sounds really nice but it's
actually far from our reality because
many of us have been brought up with the
belief system that we have to suffer to
succeed that we have to feel pain to
have purpose that we have to have
struggles in order to feel a sense of
Serenity in our life that is all quite
backwards it's when we feel good that we
actually attract more of what we want
into our life but we have to undo the
belief system that says who am I to feel
good who am I to feel great who am I to
be happy that belief system is an
ingrained belief system that can be
cultural that can be something that we
learned from our upbringing it can be
something that we have picked up from
this difficult experience that we're
going through right now with covid when
we witness people suffering we think
well how dare I be happy I would say to
you how dare you not be happy it's your
happiness it's the collective happiness
it's the group Collective happiness that
raises the energetic frequency of the
world if we those of us who have moments
of happiness and Grace and joy and
success and we don't celebrate them we
are doing the world a disservice we are
shutting down the light we are bringing
down the vibration so we we have to when
we feel good we have to reach for more
when we feel good we have to recognize
that that good feeling emotion has
momentum it has power it elevates our
children it elevates our family member
it elevates our friends it elevates
strangers on the street it is your
Divine Duty here on Earth to bring forth
that greatness that goodness that light
so when you hear that voice that says to
you you are not worthy of feeling good I
want you to hear my voice come through
and say to you who are you not to feel
good
this is your Divine Purpose it is your
mission and it is the way that you heal
and serve you got me we are more
comfortable being uncomfortable than we
are being happy
so when things are good and when we
start to get a sense of feeling good
our ego the voice of fear within us
starts to say hell no too good to be
true and it will find these weird little
Corners to pick up problems
we have a fault-finding mindset rather
than a solution happiness oriented
mindset so when that happens the next
time you notice that you're feeling good
and all is well and all of a sudden
you're like but I wasn't nice enough to
that person or my co-workers aren't in a
good place or I didn't do that right I
want you to speak back to that voice I
want you to say thank you for sharing
but I choose happiness instead
thank you for sharing but I don't
believe that voice anymore thank you for
sharing but I'm choosing this moment
give yourself permission in the moment
to speak back to the fault-finding voice
and start to claim the greatness of who
you are that is a pattern because you've
lived your life in a habitual pattern of
seeking problems and finding fault now
we have to redirect and create a new
habit and pattern of grounding you in
the truth of who you are which is
happiness joy peace and Grace sharing
that happiness joy and peace with so
much grace
that's what you're here for I think one
of my first things in failure
is don't take it more personally than it
actually is and I'll give an example of
that when I was applying to 40 companies
that all rejected me before an interview
yeah all I was getting was an automated
response saying your application will
not go any further
I can't take that personally because
they didn't meet me in person they
didn't have a interaction with me they
just saw my name they saw I'd been a
monk for three years that resume is
useless I mean what's your transferable
skills like sitting in silence surprise
surprise no one wants to hire a monk and
so they've rejected you but that's not
personal because they didn't meet me in
person but what if they had me right so
that's the first thing the first step is
don't take all fear failure I'll give an
example me and you we reach out to
countless guests to be on our podcast
which I know all the time we're saying
all the time but if I don't hear a no
from the guest directly that's not a no
like someone's team can say no someone's
assistant can say no someone's PR team
can say no but until they say no
personally it's not a no okay but when
they do say no then that's enough yeah
so then let's move how do you deal with
that type of failure yes so if I deal
with a failure where someone meets me in
person and gets to know no Jay you're
horrible you suck like I don't want to
deal with a monk ever in my life yeah I
would never go on your show I'm never
listening to you never yeah how do you
deal with that type of so I've had you
say this I've said a couple of times and
I'm sure it's been repeated a bunch of
times around how I genuinely believe
failure has feedback feedback and and so
for me it's like failure has the ability
to actually tell you what you need to
improve now not to improve to get their
attention
improving to get the actions that you
want to take yeah with the results you
want the results you want and don't make
that result about the person who said no
don't try use failure as a way to prove
someone else wrong because what happens
when we prove others wrong when you
prove others wrong you end up trying to
get validation and approval for them and
now if they're not impressed when you're
right you lose again so you end up
losing twice and you spend all this time
and energy years maybe to prove
something wrong I've been there many
times and then you're like I felt good
for a moment yeah and then I feel empty
again totally and and so that's the
thing about failure in the second half
is you have to see failure as an
improvement if if I'm completely honest
everyone who rejected me in my life up
until now
has made me more hungry taught me so
much more about myself and made me up my
game yeah and I think if failure doesn't
make you up your game it's the same as
losing in a sport
right when you fail and you've lost
games and you've won games on the big
stages you didn't have the skills you
didn't have the teamwork you guys
weren't hungry enough you were
communicating enough there's something
you were missing yeah so you go review
the game film you check the stats you
see what could have done better and you
try to improve that for the next game
yeah I think a lot of people can do that
in life but we're so afraid to like go
on the next game of life like I got
rejected once and it hurts so bad yeah
how do people learn to overcome that
pain of rejection yeah to keep going
yeah you know in sports luckily there's
a season which like you might have 30
basketball games after you lose the
first two you don't say I'm just gonna
give up the rest of the season yeah you
keep playing yes but in life a lot of
people stop playing yeah why yeah I
think that's great mental training too I
think Sports is great mental training
because you have to show up to the next
game even if you lost and you don't feel
bad exactly that you don't feel good
sorry and and one of the things before I
dive into that question one of the
things that you reminded me of was that
the Lost dance documentary so good
there's that season that Michael Jordan
everyone is agreement in an agreement
that he is one of the best players to be
playing and they keep losing and they
didn't make a fight they didn't make the
finals they lost and then they realized
they need to get the team and they need
to find the I think they're bringing
Dennis Rodman and then they start
bringing in all these other players that
strengthen whereas if they would have
just said oh we got the best player in
the world we just keep doing this
I'm not sure what they would have got
there right but the coach Phil Jackson
and the team they had to adapt and so
you're saying why do we feel that pain
in rejection and how do we deal with
that
I think we feel that pain because we
look at a failure right we look at it as
a complete definition of us right we're
looking at as as uh there's that famous
statement of like you know failure is an
event not a person right and I don't
know who said it but it's one of those
statements that that really clicks like
failure is uh an event not a person
whereas we start thinking we are the
failure like we say I am a failure
your personality literally ad is made up
of how you think how you act and how you
feel
and how you think how you act and how
you feel is your personality and your
personality is intimately connected to
your personal reality your life so then
if you want to change your life your
personal reality you got to change your
personality and here we go again you got
to start becoming conscious of your
unconscious thoughts you got to start
noticing how you act how you speak you
got to pay attention to how you're
feeling some people would live in guilt
their whole entire life and don't even
know it's guilt because at least it
feels like them so then when you start
doing that you begin to objectify your
subjective self so so then
when you begin to make small changes
back the thought a new thought should
lead to a new Choice a new Choice should
lead to a new Behavior a new Behavior
should create a new experience and a new
experience should create a new emotion
yes and that new emotion is teaching
your body chemically to understand what
your mind is intellectually understood
now your body is embodying the truth
right so then the new emotion should
Inspire new thoughts and that's called
Evolution so how do we get stuck
it's really simple
the stronger the emotion you feel from
some event in your life be it a betrayal
or a trauma or whatever yes the more
altered you feel inside of you the more
you pay attention to the cause outside
of you so the brain takes a snapshot it
freezes an image and embosses that
pattern neurologically in the brain
that's called the memory so we create
long-term memories from strong emotional
events okay so is that true that I just
want to understand the maybe the larger
the event in terms of its emotion to the
stronger of a hold it has over you yeah
well the more it's embossed in your
biology so some certain people have a
strong experience in their life and it
catches all of the brain's attention so
now they think neurologically within the
circuits of the past experience and they
feel chemically within the boundaries of
those emotions and so how you think and
how you feel creates a state of being
now here's the problem
that if you don't know how to mediate or
control your emotional reaction to that
event and you keep that refractory
period of chemicals going on extended
periods of time so that the event
produces a chemical change and the body
needs to return back to homeostasis or
balance but if it can't then the
elongation of that emotional reaction
for weeks say for days or weeks is
called the mood so you say Ed what's
wrong with you I'm in a mood why are you
in a mood well this thing happened to me
five days ago and I'm having one long
emotional reaction so then what you do
is you keep telling the story about it
keep firing and wiring the same circuits
and you keep conditioning the body into
the past so then you wake up in the
morning you look for the emotion
so then now all of a sudden you keep it
lingering for for for weeks or months
that's called the temperament well why
is he so angry I don't know let's ask
him why are you so angry well this thing
happened to me eight months ago I'm
having one long emotional reaction I'm
memorizing my emotions you keep it going
on for years on end that's called a
personality trait so then a person then
is memorizing themselves by living in
the past and so then you say to them
well tell me the story now the latest
research on memory says that 50 percent
of what we talk about in our past isn't
even the truth so we make stuff up about
the past in other words people are
reliving a life that they didn't even
have just to reaffirm that they can't
change right wow so then what's the
significance of this where you place
your attention is where you place your
energy period yes so then the stronger
the emotion that you have the some
problem or condition or person in your
life the more you're paying attention to
them so they captured your attention so
you're giving your power hour away wow
to that person right because they're
capturing your attention so then there's
an energetic connection to every person
everything everything in your past
present reality has your energy
connected to it so now this is the
significance when a person really
decides to be defined by a vision of the
future instead of the memory of the past
the hardest part about it is all of a
sudden becoming conscious and not making
the same unconscious choice so then
if you lower the volume to your
frustration to your hatred to your anger
if you truly knew how to do that if you
lower the volume to that emotion you
would take your attention off that
person which means you would begin to
break those energetic bonds and now
you're taking your power back yes you're
calling energy back to you and we've
measured this and all of a sudden it
builds this bigger electro magnetic
field around the person's body that's
energy to heal that's energy to create a
new future with right and then if you
didn't want to lower the volume to the
emotion then just take your attention
off the person and every time you take
your attention off the person if you
became conscious of that you wouldn't
feel the emotion now the body though has
been addicted to that emotion because
you're using that person to reaffirm
your addiction to hatred or frustration
and if that person died you'd find
another one so then here you go now so
now you're in a position now where you
begin to lower the volume to that
emotion and the body's going wait a
second you've been you've been doing
this for the last 20 years and all of a
sudden you're just going to stop hating
and the body says well I've been
conditioned this way and conditioning is
based on the past so when the body feels
the the lack of that emotion just like a
drug addict it says hey you're off
schedule here so now the body starts
influencing the mind to think about
experiences that are embossed in the
brain that are based on that emotion so
the emotion now is causing you to think
in the past if we teach a person then
how to trade that frustration or that
hatred for an elevated emotion and
they'll say yeah but you know it was my
ex's fault or I got betrayed by my
partner in business yeah yeah we know
that okay so let's take your partner in
business or take your ex let's duct tape
them put them in a cannon and shoot them
to the moon now what are you gonna do
sooner or later you got to reckon with
yourself and change right so then teach
a person then how to trade that emotion
for an elevated emotion now trade the
emotion for an elevated emotion right so
you're going to give that up and you're
going to practice feeling gratitude for
as an example yes the person says well I
can't feel gratitude and I say
absolutely you can because you don't
practice feeling it you practice
spending most of your time feeling
hatred and frustration so now it's going
to take a little time to cause that
heart of you to bloom or your heart of
yours to bloom once they're able to feel
even the smallest measure of gratitude
where they start feeling appreciation
thankfulness
gratitude it's emotional signature when
you when you get something when you're
receiving something
when something has happened to you
uh or when something is happening to you
you say thank you because you're
receiving something so the emotional
signature
of gratitude means the event has already
happened or it's happening to you so the
moment you open your heart and you feel
gratitude well that emotion then is
telling the body that the experience has
already occurred and the thought then
can make it into the body because it's
consistent with the thought so now
you're beginning to program the
autonomic nervous system into a very
specific Destiny you got to maintain
that modified State of Mind and Body
your entire day independent of the
conditions in your outer environment
independent of your body's Cravings of
those emotions and habituations and
independent from time and if you can get
ready because something weird or unusual
some synchronicity some coincidence some
opportunity is going to land in your lap
and you didn't have to go and get it yes
it came to you now you're the vortex of
creation so if you say to me well I was
feeling gratitude but then there was
traffic or my co-worker sent me a nasty
email that I would say oh my God God you
mean you're allowing your environment
your outer environment to control how
you feel and think you're back to the
unconscious program that you're the
victim to your life you got it but when
you start producing those outcomes in
your life you're going to pay attention
to what you did inside of you and you're
going to believe more that you're the
creator of your life unless of the
victim of your life research study and
psychology found out that both second
person and third person makes you more
it makes yourself talk more powerful so
if you're gonna do affirmations you
wouldn't just say I want to do this I
want to do this you want to do what we
call in the book self-coaching where you
would say you know in my case yeah
Brendan it's important you do a good job
here today because you usually don't do
interviews and you really love Marie and
you want to do a good job for her and
her people and this is a book you worked
on for three years and it's important it
does well and Brendan don't forget
you're so lucky you get to do this
brother so just enjoy the process you're
so lucky Brendan
that's a different level of going I'm
lucky I'm lucky right it is I'm Brendan
yes yes another one another one I do
every morning in the shower yeah
assuming I take a shower but every
morning in the shower because we all
don't every day not every morning no we
do not it just doesn't happen it does
nothing it doesn't happen I told you
like 24 hours ago I was staying at a
barn in the woods at a friend's house
yeah
um but the second thing I asked myself
in the in the shower every morning is
what might happen today that could trip
me up
um and how are you going to bring your
best self to that Brendan
I say that every morning in the shower
to myself and it just helps me
anticipate that you know what
something's going to go wrong during the
day absolutely and if I already know
everything like like this mornings was
okay you're in I think what we would I
think I'm yes North Manhattan where I'm
staying would you call it North you're
Uptown I'm uptown and you're coming to
um let's just call it downtown okay so
I'm like okay that's going to be 45
minutes it's a hot summer day yes I I'm
gonna get hot and I know when I'm hot
sometimes I get impatient yes and I get
stressed and I don't want to feel that
so just pay attention to how you're
feeling on your way down to the
interview with Marie Brendan and really
just engage pay attention be present
with New York and really enjoy that
you're here I know that sounds
completely crazy but every High
performing athlete does it every
salesperson does it I mean a high level
every person I interviewed who are at
what we call the top 15 of all high
performers they all self-talk and most
of them we found we're doing in second
and third
which is amazing I love it I think it's
so fun yeah little things yeah so if you
already talk to yourself and you say
your name to yourself and they're not
crazy you're probably high performing
because you made it this far in a video
I want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
Nation you made it here all the way to
the end and I love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome to learn
about the law of attraction Secrets
check the video right there next to me I
think you'll love it continue to believe
and I'll see you there if the person's
doing the vision board and they're
saying when I get my new car I get my
new house I get my new relationship then
I'm gonna feel so great now that well
then they're back to the program